okay
for people joining this live stream we
are talking about spatial statistics
functionality for version 12.2 of
language
uh for those who are keeping track
apparently this is the 400th
livestream design review that we have
done so
that's a lot of pieces of functionality
designed
live and in public and uh we hope people
like this kind of open design process
and um uh you'll see in version 12.2
we'll actually start linking to some of
these videos
in the functions that have been designed
as part of this
live stream design review process
okay onward spatial statistics
so where are we starting today so one of
the things that you haven't gone through
and i think it's useful because you you
asked about sort of a
a radial distribution function which we
didn't know what it was
which was paired correlation g so those
five
or six functions there are homogeneity
measures to the left
or or in that guide page too um those
are useful to go through
okay but then we haven't even started in
on processes yet
you know but this page which will
eventually be basically
spatial statistics there's something
here spatial bin data so i didn't look
at that that's oh yeah okay let me
explain
the description should that have been
listed here is that just a mistake or is
this
it's a mistake it should have been
listed there okay fine and this
was the reason we have this is that
it turns out that as of today
or for privacy reasons a lot of data
is not available as detailed point data
sure so for instance
um you might get crime data that's not
narrowed down to the actual house right
right or
disease epidemiology the stuff that geo
region value plot would plot
is this region arrow value type stuff it
would be yes
okay but now you can compute with it so
we have what we've done and this is
slightly questionable but
we we for many functions you can
actually use this
aggregated data and what we will take so
the only thing you know about it
is a constant value you know the
intensity
i see okay so like with monte carlo yes
for purposes of things like the smooth
point density yes if i say
if i say if i've got spatial bin data
and then i say
smooth point density i've got spatial
bin data for france and spain
and i say smooth point density that will
show a smooth interpolation because it
has effectively
uh created it with points so to speak
yeah so that will then start going
through almost
all of our functions it will translate
bin data to point data okay so
hold on hold on hold on hold on we could
as well do that
for when we have histogram distribution
right we could have been doing that
there couldn't we
yes in ordinary statistics so what we
didn't do there but we need to go
back and do and let's come up from user
suggestions
like for histogram to take pre-bin data
already
because you often get it as i said like
traffic data
if you get traffic counts you often get
it per
you know okay so hold on so what you're
proposing is that we have something
so there's a whole calculus of bin data
presumably
because you know given two sets of bin
data you could add it together if the
bins agree it'll
you know the values should add if um
if you want if you have disjoint bins
you should be able to combine them and
so on right
so we've not tried to implement a
calculus like that
um the
it's pretty bad what happens the the
growth
with none you know when bins don't agree
um the
you typically get sort of the product of
number of bins
and you keep getting the product so it
grows exponentially typically
okay question i mean you know we have
somebody implementing this mcmc
tech bayesian technique and so on is
that
relevant to this whole story or is that
something irrelevant to this we have our
own mcmc engine that we wrote
uh so that's simulating a lot of these
processes now when we do
um um well wait a minute how is that
relating to this
um joseph guys mcmc project
sushma is dealing with i have no idea we
did this many years ago
why didn't we expose the mcmc method
then
well
i mean people have really wanted that
for episodes it's a very custom
this is very custom code very optimized
for for the task at hand it's not very
general
civic place okay all right fine okay
okay can somebody make that connection
please with with
sushma and joseph so that you can at
least see what he's done
you know do i need to send mail about
that yeah do send mail
yeah but you know what we need a project
manager in these meetings that's kind of
the deal
yeah i mean i can't i could be in the
mail for that yes please do
that's kind of your role here
okay so
um let's go back talking about bin data
so do you imagine
that beyond spatial bin data that there
is a
a another there's just a function called
bind data
possibly yeah so we have something right
now which is much more limited
called histogram list which is sort of
an
output that does the binning for you
but but i think we need a container like
that if we have the container
then a lot of functions would could just
work on it like histogram with all this
stuff yes i agree
you know this this is broken by the way
for the 12-2 prototype build this
open function page thing is broken
matt are you able to well maybe it
doesn't i don't know
i didn't know about this function what
is this oh yeah i remember what this is
yeah
i remember this yeah and it's only can
only do
uh rectangular bins
right so it doesn't do histogram binding
in 2d 3d and so on
it does but they're rectangular so it
doesn't can't do it into regions
basically
no no
now
presumably that b spec could be
generalized to regions yes
yeah it's very hard-coded to some
product no but that's not
you're not going to make a new function
for this i mean we got a function that
does this
right that that makes that's not the
problem the data is coming in
as the output from this function this
one i understand i understand
this this is taking point data and
turning it into histogram data
so this is creating binned data so
except presented as a list yes
so what this is representing so
so spatial bin data here is representing
something
which is which is you know there's one
thing which is the binning process
that is saying i want to bin things by
country for example here is my raw data
i'm going to bin them by country and
then i only want to manipulate it bin by
country
right yes so okay so there's one thing
which is the the creator of this
and then this is the container of data
bin by country
yes right
so why isn't this name spatial region
data
to spatial point data
i mean spatial point data describes the
things
at which you have data right
yeah i mean but
um
and i don't quite understand why spatial
point data
you know is is basically it's either a
point
i mean how does this relate to for
example what happens with with time
series and temporal data and so on where
you can in principle specify i mean we
have the exact same issue there
you can either say this week
you know the weather was good or at this
instant
the you know sky you know
cover was such and such am i making
sense
how are we representing those two things
i
i don't know well so i'm talking about
granularity if we've got
a an a time series or a date series
an event series okay and we've got date
objects with different granularities
right so let's say we have a thing with
a granularity of a week and it says that
there were five people or you know five
um
you know there were
five toads in the enclosure that week
okay
so but that's a weak granularity thing
as opposed to at this instant there was
you know we observed this
toad in the in you know and where i see
what you're saying in the pond
so i don't know um i mean
the the depends on what your question is
is the question is should we simulate
that data up
no that's not what i think it's like
very careful about that yeah no i agree
i agree i'm asking a different question
i'm asking about these containers
and i'm asking what is the structure
look what we've got here
is we've got the idea of point data
right
okay so what we've got is data which is
of the form where
arrow what right that's the basic form
of our data
correct yeah okay so the where
in the case many of our functions is the
raw coordinate value
right right but the where could also be
geoposition
etc the where could also be a data
object
yes now one feature of a data object is
it has granularity to it
right right that is similar but not the
same thing but it's similar thing
to this region region thing here for geo
regions
yes okay i could also imagine
something in a in a different world of
computational geometry
where you are saying things like polygon
has this value
right sure where you've got something
that represents so
my question to you is why
is this
not a general spatial data
concept where the left-hand side is just
where
on the right-hand side is what
do you see i'm saying why are we
distinguishing between between points
and regions yes
well they are very different behaviors i
mean to begin with here right
is from this perspective of point data
there are many points in a region or
potentially many points
no i understand i understand so they're
not the same
they i understand that okay but why do
you want to uni i mean i don't know what
you gain by unifying
them except an awful lot of complexity
is going to be pushed to the user
well i think the opposite actually but i
mean i'm the question is
what you're saying is in this case
in this case what we're doing
okay you're saying in this case
it is binned but simulated as points
yes correct yes
so it's not completely obvious to me
that that name makes that clear
that's somewhat somewhat reasonable
somewhat reasonable
the place that we're coming from you
know to the spatial bin data is that
uh ms roger explained it's the
aggregated data and so
the important feature is that you know
think about this as a beans so the
disjoint the regions are disjoint so you
kind of have your
you know covering of your you know
observation you know area that you have
and so you have these regions so
so so so this and um and then the
assumption is
that you have you can you can you know
think about simulating this
you know in the way that it's uniform
over your regions and then
work with the other statistics i i got
all of that i got
all of that so that is why one is called
spatial point data
and the other is called spatial bin data
which is simulated points but doesn't
have the word point in its name
well we could have call it bin spatial
bin point data
maybe we should maybe we should we
should because i don't think that the um
um i think it's it's pretty good idea
actually i feel more comfortable with
that because we're gonna have
i mean yeah that's a complicated concept
and i think it's the right thing to do
rather than make it
yeah i think it's true um
it's amazingly much data that's
published by zip code or some such
absolutely okay so then then explain i
think we have happen to have jose here
and i presumably for the geo part of
this
can jose comment on the on the um time
series and
date object part of this story i mean is
there a similar thing that we'll want to
do for
for time series so i think the case of
dates is special in that we have merged
the instant case with the discrete case
right so in general we don't we didn't
mix
like numbers with intervals or points
with regions etc so dates is special in
that sense
so it is an exception in my view rather
than
okay all right okay all right listen um
listen by the way in terms of note
taking here am i taking these notes
basically
shall i just take these notes do we have
a a um
does anybody know where i'm putting
these things
um anybody even know that
spam protection probably not
okay anybody know that come on that's a
pretty minimal thing to know from a
project management point of view
nope nobody have any idea okay fine
all right okay so
all right so just to finish the comment
i think in in time series
the thing will be just to require that
we have something of a definite um
granularity and then we can
just use dates of common granularity
it's
the same thing we are doing with data
interval that interval contains a
granularity
so we just project things today variety
of that data
right
um okay
let's see that comments on our live
stream here
um
okay ethan is asking about lidar clouds
with tens of millions of points
so that's not here i was i did a study
of that
those kinds of point clouds they're
primarily sampling a continuous surface
is what the point of that data is that's
the kind of thing that's returned by
for instance some of our image import
functions now like heif import can
import
effectively depth values and
yeah the issue is the scalability of the
stuff and
and things like you know when will
graphics 3d be able to deal with 10
million points
i think it's a different team no but it
can deal with that today
um you know and and we deal with five to
ten million polygons and so on
fair enough okay i see here is asking
about
geographic positions of lightning will i
be able to compute the probability of my
house getting hit with lightning
a reasonable question what would you do
given that given that scenario by the
way the lightning database is a nice
database of point data
point well that's points as a function
of time right
do you know what i'm talking about yeah
but but we would take out the time we
would just use them
but now we're taking out the time but in
the future
what do we imagine if we wanted that
with time what would it look like
don't know i mean we have to think about
sort of space i mean the question is
whether it's time outside or time inside
among other things
yeah both of those you can imagine you
know yeah time is usually
treated differently um generally
speaking in all of statistics
because you don't usually want to
predict from the future
you don't want to use data from the
future to predict you want to use data
from the past to predict
that's very different from spatial where
you can use all the data around you
yes well right
we let's not go into the the discussion
of the physics of time but yes
very different concept yep but in any
case
okay but but i mean what we would
imagine there is that there will be
we could imagine a time series of
spatial point data
at some point in the future is that
right is that what you would
i think we need something else then time
series for what what all the
wild things that we're starting to call
time series i realized that we need it
but it's not going to be time series
where you can actually operate on it
then
it's just going to be a container thing
a very general thing and then you can
have
a time series of footballs and ears
and chemicals and whatever you want yeah
well we'll it'll
need to use that name but but it might
work differently
yeah it will work differently and it it
will be more of a just a container
and there will be something small yeah
so we have that actively being worked on
at this point time series
no ouch we need to talk about that
yeah um
one comment for a particular case of
events points in time
the opposition can handle time so
it's possible to just store at your
position of lots of events with
timestamps
ethan is saying that it isn't true that
we can handle tens of millions of points
in graphics 3d
and that uh uh is pointing out that
needs to use gpu acceleration which
graphics 3d
well does not have in the in the kernel
it's it presumably has it in the front
end
yeah yeah i you know
okay um he might be right
well i mean but there are obvious things
it's like did you do a point wrapper
around each point and then just the
expression creation will kill you
uh if you do a point of the list of
packed array data of 10 million points
then there's a good chance you could do
it
right you got to get it past all of
those things first
right
so the the um
um and if they're totally random which
they usually aren't from lighter cloud
they usually sort of form some
continuous surface
um so they can actually show something
decent if they're just random
i think you'll just see black i mean
you'll see nothing
that many but if they're points sampled
on a surface they're gonna make that
surface look
almost continuous that's a good function
to put in here
um normal distribution
no random variant probably you want
um you can use
can i do random variation on the surface
no
but i can do random point on a surface
can't i yes
how would i do that i would just say
random point
on what on on on sphere
yeah and then i would do like 10 random
points on a sphere
okay and then i would do like uh
let's do 10 to the five random points on
a sphere
and then let's say point of that
and then let's say graphics 3d yeah
of that i was pretty zippy
yeah that was very impressive yeah
that's a hundred thousand points and
if you give them if you also give them
a hundred thousand normals that will
actually look nice
well this is already i mean that was
quite impressive
so i mean if i yeah there we go
but but see if you get the normals
they're going to look continuous so
you're going to start seeing the actual
surface
yeah i don't care about that i want to
just try let's just try should we try 10
million
why not
it's grinding it's spinning
i don't know how much the random point
generation is taking it out but it's
probably taking some
significant chunk too yeah oh i've
zoomed that's right i've zoomed in here
okay well
it rendered 10 million points um
okay so ethan is saying that the things
he's sending are 100 times faster than
this
okay well we should look at it yeah but
i don't think it's for this team
no i mean they're dedicated point
renderers that are trying to render just
that this is sort of a scheme of
rendering
point-based rendering and then of course
it's fully optimized for that
right and you're not putting a notebook
container and so on well this is
um okay anyway let's go on um
uh this question about geographic
position lightning somebody's asking how
is the lightning measured actually it's
measured very generally
in the world it's because very easy to
tell where lightning is you just look at
the um
you just look at electric fields right
that's how it um uh
um i think we we there's a lightning
database
um isn't that one of the data sets gosha
that you have there
i don't have lighting but the the the
question kind of
it's the what's the empty space f is
computing
so that that's the you know like when
you have a tornado index on you know on
there
right we should have a lightning desk
because but the fact is we have
there is very good lightning data um
i will look it up and see yeah
here's a nasa one we have somebody um
um
who's going through all these nasa
databases trying to make them
available in our geo image functionality
um
okay uh
right
that's a decent suggestion providing a
an application section that
shows a large database being used in
particular
in for different functions yes okay
let's see a comment from sander here
um okay so this is the question about
bin's
multiple overlapping bins and what
happens how we combine
bins but that's not what you're doing in
this case in this case you're simply
re-sampling
is that correct yes
but there is a question of user input if
the user gives
overlapping bins what do we do
i'm saying um
right what do you mean what do you do
and and do do we do we try to it is
super expensive to compute
all the cross intersections and and
[Music]
and re-split them i don't think we are
doing that at the moment
no we are not well but you can do it but
monte carlo yes
no but the question how do you treat the
input that has overlapping beans
you know should we check that should
what should you do should you trim the
beans to be
you know if you're doing watercolor why
do you care you're just sampling in the
bins that are specified aren't you
yeah but if they overlap you know you're
saying that so what
i mean what does that mean here here's
like two
geographic regions the number of disease
cases
it could be that sometimes you're saying
function with two values and so on right
same thing right right right so it's a
question of
it's like region combinations like
constructive geometry right is it the
xor of the regions
or is it the union you know is it the
ore of the regions
right and so right now we we required it
that be a disjoint
i mean okay but the alternative the easy
thing to do from a monte carlo point of
view would be to
do the ore of the two regions correct
but it's just sampling sure sure you can
do that but but is that what it was
intentioned
what was that i don't know i don't know
but i mean what you're saying is
the alternative would be that you notice
that a particular sub region
is double covered and you d and you
sample only once but if you've got two
different values if one
region you know if france well what's a
double covered region i don't know we
could say
um uh
i don't know the some i don't know new
york city versus
the state new york state okay so new
york city had a value of 10 and new york
state had a value of one
uh those were the density values for
those two places
what do we do in that case
right right so that's a that's a good
question
it seems to me that we should know you
know that issue has surely come up in
the work we've done on endless sort of
census bureau data and so on i don't
think anybody in this meeting would know
about it
but it will be interesting to ask alan
what has happened in those cases
right unless jose knows something about
that
does that certainly come up it will have
come up in our
analysis of of uh covert data and all
kinds of other things
of what to do with backing out
overlapping regions
so can can you follow up with with um i
i think michael might know something
allen might know
something about that but let's i mean
what you're doing right now is you're
generating error if the region's overlap
is that correct
i think so yeah gosha can you speak to
that
um we might i mean we basically right
now
you know take in the whole goodness and
then see what happens
but we would like you know like to check
that it's just super expensive
that's what roger said so you know if we
wait
wait wait wait wait wait so the point is
what we started with this discussion was
that you don't allow overlapping regions
but now you're saying you don't check
for whether the regions are overlapping
well
so the ques so okay so there is a there
is a problem here between
you know a user who provides a
non-overlapping regions
and wants the thing to go fast and the
user who doesn't i don't know if there
is
and once so i think we should basically
give an option
where you check for that like you check
assumptions so you're gonna check that
and then we're going to check for that
and it's going to take longer and it's
going to be yeah
what does it do by default so we have
some code
that is disabled so i commented it out
that would check for overlapping right
now is no
it's okay i understand but what does it
do what is the mathematical definition
of what it does
right now if you give two overlapping
regions does it take i think it assumes
that they are not overlapping
and then proceeds you know so you get
incorrect results but it will error
when no no you're not answering my
question
if you're doing monte carlo sampling and
you've got a region which has a one
value and a region that has a three
value
what do you actually you're going to
sample both of those so you're
effectively getting a four region
in the the overlap is effectively a four
is that correct
yes okay that's fine that's well
documentable
yes that's or that's documentable that's
what it does
if you don't want the regions to overlap
then either make sure they don't overlap
or set the option to check overlapping
yes that's actually reasonable that's
actually a really good solution
thank you but we also have some some
code that uses mesh regions
and mess regions have to be constructed
uh
correctly and not overlapping and on
that so there will be a clash of
behavior between
giving a list of regions and giving
cells that would be
mesh regions what do you mean no
eduardo the mesh regions would
guaranteed be
non-overlapping that's not going to be a
problem yeah like
mass regions work like if you give if
you try to construct a mesh region that
is overlapping
it won't work no that's what i'm saying
exactly right but it won't work at the
source because the overlapping because
the mesh region itself won't allow
overlap
exactly okay fine this is not a problem
yeah right so so
but i mean in in the case where we check
for overlaps
given that we're bothering to check for
olaps why don't we just define what the
overlap function is
do you see what i'm saying so the
overlap function could be average it
could be uh
take the larger it could be you know all
the obvious things
right i mean does that make sense so
then the the default is simply or
or actually the default is basically
plus
because it's it's what do you do for the
weightings of the two things
yes and you know it could also be max it
could also be
you know zero for if it overlaps all
those kinds of things
yes um
okay uh
okay let's go on here all right so we
agreed we're renaming these things mean
density mean point density right that's
this
that's that one mean point density um
and so then in the case where you say
mean point density of a spatial bind
mean point density of spatial bin point
data
within a specified region right that
these take a second argument which is
the bounding region is that correct
is that correct look at it i don't know
i think that should do it doesn't
oh gosh this doesn't work oh me
intensity
did you rename it or something no i mean
point intensity
we changed it in the guide but i didn't
change it in this design
okay no problem um
why don't you give it why don't you
allow it to take a second argument with
a region that seems useful to me
it gives you okay so here's the
situation
you've got a big data set and um
uh you know of europe showing the bin
you know
gridded population for europe and you
want
the mean point density
for france in other words you're cookie
cuttering out
you know that region yes yes
does that make sense yes totally you
just select the points which are lying
in your sub region
and then you compute you know the number
of points you get over the area of your
sub region yes
right seems seems sensible to me
that that's i mean that that
functionality exists
we may we may also extend it here to
this function
the functionality exists by by wrapping
spatial point data with it with a region
around your point data to basically well
to sub select that yes but also it you
know we
can um compute certain information from
special point data
so yes okay now remind me spatial point
select well that's that's a different
story that that it's to select
by points and yeah values of annotations
so how do i get the criterion to apply
to the
value itself i mean this is like a key
value select
right because from that point
oh this is the thing which we called
hash point which i was complaining about
did we solve that or not
i thought you were okay with it at that
point
you know and the thing that you said
that the very common case of
of um
constraining to a region actually
spatial point data
of spatial point data comma region does
that right
right which we had implemented which you
suggested also
both come to the same conclusion okay
but but now this thing about hash point
what is the conditions on the point what
is the thing being fed to hash point
is it a point or is it the coordinates
of the point
so it's the coordinates of the point if
it's just
one of these in a cartesian and it's a
geoposition
if it's a if it's a you know if it's a
geospatial point
yeah all right we went through that
discussion before all right i'm i'm okay
with it being called point i guess
but but don't for goodness sake you've
got to emphasize
oh boy and and in the case where the
there's a key called point what does it
do
i don't know yet i need to
think that through okay all right
i just assumed very unlikely case but i
don't think that
yes no i mean one is going to take
precedence and i
i assume that sort of the the keyword
point here is going to take precedent
i think it has to i think i think it has
to be otherwise you can't get to it
yes yeah um okay
fine all right let's keep going here um
all right
uh i think we went through all of these
these point density functions and so on
we went through all of that stuff
i think so yeah okay what we didn't do
is the homogeneity measures
oh yeah and point count distribution we
haven't looked at
right let's look at point count
distribution
so that takes a process in a point
processing rather than a point
set okay by the way
do these work with the same annotation
framework and regions of interest
as in images and plots
oh it's the other it works with the
formal annotation framework yes
in what sense so so can we haven't added
annotations to images yet
um we have added annotations to audio
graph
and um
geometry regen mesh features okay so
ethan is asking does it support
highlighting
no should it well you can give the
you can specify you know certain you
know annotation
per highlight you may say zero one and
your ones will will refer to the
highlighting
so you can you can you know you can
achieve the same effect but there is no
highlight function
because it's not visual per se yeah
sorry say that again about how you
achieve it
you can use you can use an annotation
you can call it highlight or whatever it
is yeah yeah right but they're two
different kinds
and they will be colored differently you
know when you use those
attributes but point value plot will
color them or
or or show them differently yes which
you can control how it does that too
yeah
all right so point count distribution so
this is you're throwing darts
at something and this is telling you
this is like your gaussian distribution
of darts or something is that right
yeah it's not gaussian in this case it's
most likely poisson when we have the
poison point process that's gonna be a
poisson distribution the number of
points
so in every realization of the point
process with in the given region you get
some number of points this is a random
variable
and this random variable follows a
certain distribution
and so for like poisson point process
this is a poisson distribution
and for some other processes we don't
have the closed form but we can
represent it as a transform distribution
so in a way point account distribution
is a derived distribution
and even if we don't have if we don't
have the closed form
for that we can you know if things are
numeric we can simulate that
right through the for the point process
simulation
okay in which case you get a
non-parametric distribution right
okay so wait a minute if i say point
count distribution of a plus on point
process that's a two-dimensional one
there
yeah you happen to know it for this
particular region
and this process we happen to have a
closed form right
but but if i were to take there a
rectangle for example i mean i don't
understand this very well is this
it's going to give you the mute that's a
poisson distribution
where the where the coefficient the
parameter in the distribution
is mu the coming from the poisson point
process times the area of the region
in this case so the measure of the
region cool
i like the pentagon better
um okay so this is your throwing things
in there
and the point count distribution is
telling you how many counts you will get
within that region is that correct
yes yes
here's an interesting thing stephen yeah
you could say that
if you knew the point count distribution
for all possible collections of regions
not a single region but but you can you
can see that next use case
is when you have multiple regions
if you know all of those you know the
process
there's a there's a very infinite stack
of possible things you need to do i
understand so
but essentially those regions of a
french is
in the end they slice space down
to particular positions right so you're
basically
saying by the time you slice space to
the point where
every spatial point is a separate region
you know what the process is
is that what you're saying roughly
speaking yes
this is the analog for random processes
if you know all possible slice
distributions
multi-slice distributions you know the
process but that's a very infinite
number of things you need to know but it
is a way a general way to define it
okay what is what are some of the let me
look at these things on this process
page
um
so
estimated point process this took us
some time
that's given data can we fit the
parameters for those mechanisms there
so
so this is given the parameter given
that it's a poisson distribution
can you determine which poisson
distribution it is is that right
process point process yeah but in this
case this is a process so
you throw it say poisson point process
means that you expect
you know uniform distribution from that
so you want to know what's the
density you know the parameter in your
poisson point process if you
throw the model which is clustered and
we're gonna try to fit
the cluster parameters you know and the
problem is that it's it's sometimes
hard to recognize so we don't you know
it's we don't have the recognition that
will tell you immediately
this is a cluster process or you know
it's a uniform that's the spatial
randomness test
here it's just exactly saying okay i
want the best parameters for this model
and that's what it is
how are you specifying that's the mu you
want out of this
like that it's a variable but how don't
you have to give
comma mu here no you just gave it there
this is exactly how estimated
distribution
i see so that's just that the name of
that variable is completely dummy
yes
that's interesting we don't have a lot
of functions like that but essentially
solve for a variable
but the variable is just being there
just sort of
being uh i mean that's how we would
usually use blanks for example
to represent an unnamed i mean you know
more
more what i would more the thing is that
what this allows
is that multiple ones that can also be
the same and so on
yeah but why why not use blanks i mean
and i mean i would expect that that
would be the thing there
that this is a it is filling in
something of that form and if you want
them to be the same
you use the way that pattern matching
you know determine
that somehow comes together that we also
have find point process parameters which
you know needs to know what what the
parameter names are and that
returns the rules for all your named
parameters
fair enough well then you don't want to
have a different inputs because then you
can
you know use them interchangeably you
know
and with the blank you will not be able
to tell you know blank blank
you know which blank is which blank well
yes unless you name them
exactly which is more like the cases
situation
right so that's why we have names to
avoid that
that communication but anyway okay
that's just the same for random
variables and random processes
okay a gibbs point process
what did old josiah willard get up to
there
it's actually easier if you start with
the all the other ones are basically
instances of this
so this is the most general form it can
take
by the way go should you see that that
call box is wrong
there's something styled with that and
the call box
yeah see that the alignment there is
just totally wrong between
the input and the text oh it's not
indented
yeah i don't know i don't know
is is this does this come from
statistical mechanics i mean is this
is this based on i mean like does this
expect to have things like elena jones
potential in it and things
what is this what i mean
well i mean i think the guy that
developed the whole
originally yes but but no we don't have
that potential
well but but the radial pair potential
function 5r
means you could put elena jones
potential in there
right you could put art yes yes it's not
a standard model
that we have but yes you can but i
understand
your standard model it says pair
potential here so
sorry by standard model we have a family
of models that are all
under the gib the gibbs is like the the
general
gibbs oh yeah the family yeah
yeah um
uh let's see there's a question from
bob can you pop plot points on a globe
rather than just a map i think that's
coming isn't it jose don't we have the
a geoplot 3d coming geographic 3d
um not in this version but yes
eventually we will have the 3d versions
of geo
and and the language for for heights
vertical high datums etc
there's a question from robert here how
would i combine a large
circuit graph like an electric grid for
utilities
with these spatial statistics primitives
e.g if i wanted to project uh
consumer growth stochastically and then
compute the effect on grid failures
so in other words how do you put a
a graph how do you layer a graph on top
of spatial statistics
interesting question it is an
interesting so there's one
here's a potential i'm interpreting what
he's
looking for in some cases like
the um the example he gave with a
utility lines with electrical lines
but also traffic they mostly happen on
effectively a graph
so then you don't want the full space
but you want it restricted to those
1d um you know so you want to change all
the measures to be the correct thing for
those
uh i think it's a different problem i
think that's another interesting problem
i don't think that's the one he's
referring to i think the question is
can you align a graph in other words if
if
okay so first point is our notion of
geograph is coming soon not here in this
version
but a geograph will be something like
the street network
for a particular city which is a graph
which is whose coordinates are pinned to
geopositions
right jose am i am i representing that
correctly
uh i think that's correct so currently
we can have
a graph in which the nodes are your
positions
and then geographics will uh just add
really yes really so if i if i just say
if i pick um how do i pick a random geo
position let's say random points
um how do i do this let's say france or
something i think it's not
random point it's under your position
this has rendered your position yes
random geoposition
okay and then if i if i if i do the
following
so what you're saying is if i say can i
break these apart does normal break them
apart
and now if i say something like nearest
neighbor graph
not sure what that's going to do
is that not computing nearest neighbors
on with respect to geo positions
okay oh whoops i should have said comma
two but now
okay this is the question can i say
geographics of this
so do geographics of of line of that
assuming that the nodes are still your
positions which i don't i'm not sure
i don't
that's a good example
very nice well done right and the idea
is that you can say
instead of lines you could say geopath
comma loxotron i need to draw
locks or drums or you can say point if
you just want the point
if you change the line to point you just
get the point of the
but what's the what's the what's the
lock drum that sounds cool
geopath command yes for this short
paths it's going to be nearly identical
what is it called locks the drum or gt7
yeah but for this very short parts you
don't see the difference
if this was through the world it would
be noticeable
right right right right right right the
key point is that you have to specify
outside the
the primitive you want you can say point
and then you just get the points or you
can say your marker and you get your
markers
right
well this is very nice you should make
sure there's an example of this
someplace
um i had no idea this would work
okay um
uh there's a question here about whether
well this is again can we draw graphs on
surfaces like spheres or do we have that
capability
no we don't we don't ship it we we did a
few of those
um actually maybe it's available as an
option but
but we haven't extended that
systematically for any shapes
um um
we did it specifically for spheres but
uh
but not more general right we are
running out of time
here i just want to make sure we get a
quick look through this
um point process stuff uh
so so fundamentally the way these point
process things work
is you're saying this is the process and
you're sampling the process
okay what is random point configuration
we went through that before right that
that is
that's a random general process yeah
that's the analog of random variate for
a configuration of points yes
the the thing here that you might get
sort of used
or find strange you need to say where
most of these all of these processes are
defined on an infinite domain
i see so if i say random point
configuration let's say it's a
random point configuration and now what
do i want
random points random point a press on
point process and a pentagon how do i do
it
you you you do um poisson point process
and then the region comma region it's
just that the mu has to be numeric
so give it ten or three you some number
okay and now what i would do for this
now how do i display this i just say
graphics of this so what do i do
you can do list both for instance this
plot but as i said you need to
extract the points for the time being in
the prototype so
the property points oh that was the
branch
class yeah i need to resolve how to
how to deal with so how many points am i
specifying here am i saying 34.
so this is part of the process itself
specifies how many points
are going to be in that region so if i
were to say 100 here that would mean the
poisson process that has more
more because you see that the number of
points is the poisson distribution
right that you have below so if you put
the the
point count distribution and you in in
place of mu you put 100 you're gonna get
the poisson distribution and the
parameter there it's gonna be the
expected number of
of points in that region so if i say
spatial point data
of oh no no if i were to do this
presumably if i were to say s mean what
you're calling mean intent mean point
intensity
yes good okay
very nice and is there a variance
concept as well
or is that not something people consider
so the not really the the second order
you know this is what we call the
homogeneity measures this is the second
order statistics
you know between two points or between
the location and a point
okay so if i say ripley k of that
it's a function so if you could put as a
second
argument r or at r then you're gonna get
a function of radius
so this tells you the the kind of
expected number of
points within radius why is there no 100
in there why isn't there 100 because it
depends on the radius so if your radius
is numeric then you're going to get a
number no i understand that but the fact
that the
i'm saying that the average of the
poisson distribution is a hundred
why is it not a hundred times the area
per unit area right
yes so it's a hundred per unit area yeah
so that's no but then why isn't it a
hundred times the area
because replica is normalized go go look
at normal
replica there's a normalization in
replica okay fine all right
okay so then let's let's take the pair
correlation function
well the point is
because this process is special right so
this
this has the constant correlation
because
it's like a normal process in this world
stephen yes everything is sort of the
sim
everything is cl clean and simplest with
the uniform or pass on point process
okay so if i take another process here
this hard
core whatever it is process that may not
have the formula
defined they may not exist the closed
form formula
you can you can only simulate
an empty list of points
spatial point data hardcore process of
this is an empty list of points so i see
so this is saying i can't directly apply
pair correlation to this
right whereas i could directly apply
pair correlation to the pass-on point
process it's not allowing me to do that
well i think that's a bug because we we
simulate that
okay so you cannot you cannot you cannot
do this with
the with the non-numeric inputs yeah
simulator right so this is symbolic
r so we don't have a closed form so we
cannot give you anything
as well well that's that's that's gonna
be a problem for us yes
okay that's a bug all right can i just
try one more process here
what would be most likely to work
process
a thomas point process whatever that
might be right
um yeah those have clas
those have closed forms for for some of
these second order
cool
very cool very nice
what does it say indeterminate true that
doesn't oh i see it's indeterminate if
r is not greater than or equal to zero
right clearly bothering is that really
worth
saying yes really
i would have thought that that was a
generate conditions arrow true and by
default
it's not there because you know anybody
who's computing a pair correlation
function with a radius
and the radius is negative is silly
we have to be you know silly proof
in a way why so if you give if you give
minus two in place
of r what do you expect oh then i expect
indeterminate
exactly so my point is this my point is
this
for the symbolic form you should have a
generate conditions option which should
be false by default
roger do you don't you agree i mean
because because this is the thing this
is what i want to see i don't want to
see all this weird nonsense
yeah i got it um we probably should
we haven't done that with any of this
we've just expanded a lot generate
conditions
of the last few years the calculus in
algebra but it
yeah i think you should do it for
statistics i mean this is the nice thing
to see
not this big mess here sure i mean do
you have an assumptions option in here
no neither assumptions nor generate
conditions because
they sort of rarely work with parameters
yeah
yeah they haven't been that's not their
primary
this is in this field like areas where
you can get closed forms
are few and far between
well i agree i agree this this this
basically this measures sort of
you know have used on data to analyze
data
right i have to go unfortunately because
i have to give a talk soon um
uh and um where do you think we are
stephen
on this i think we're one hour away from
okay
um the uh i think we're very close
but can we see it another time with with
the changes that we've already expect
in it i think that it's not going to
happen now until after the conference
unfortunately
right well fair enough but but i mean i
think we're very close
in terms of you know implementation we
should be good
i i'm a little concerned about the names
of those um
uh uh the the um what am i saying the
the um uh the names of the
properties in spatial point data seemed
a bit hicky to me
last time i looked at it um
maybe we focus in on that next time yeah
these ones here
seem a bit i mean like dimension we
agreed isn't dimensions right we went
through all of that stuff
maybe the rest of it will be this i
didn't really believe in points versus
points list i'm concerned about
fair so can we can we get that on the
agenda and um
uh okay a couple of comments on our live
stream i just want to
to look at for these asking suppose you
work at a refinery and want to overlay a
graph of your process equipment on a map
would that work i think so i think that
would work just fine with geographics
i think so too with images of equipment
absolutely it should work just fine um
uh ethan is suggesting a matterpoint
maybe we should do some of these
meetings where we try and solve a real
world problem
with our tools sometimes we do do that
actually for but they're different kinds
of meetings
um but it's a it's a um uh let's see
um okay bob is commenting um
how would you draw a histogram linked to
a map so that each country has a
cylinder come about
coming out of it representing the
country population
i'll say we've the many people that have
drawn those i
wouldn't be surprised if there is a wolf
and function repository thing
if there isn't there should be i mean
that's the 3d version of geo region
value plot
right do you know jose
i don't know but it's perfectly doable
with a bit of work
yes i'm thinking for example of that
nice
video that was created for the
for the marathon in chicago do you
remember when
in which the cylinders were actually
moving along
the marathon path
right now okay geo region value plot 3d
would be the thing maybe we can suggest
that if you feed that to sushma's list
of possible things for the function
repository to begin with
it's a good idea all right i need to run
um okay thank you great stuff and thanks
to folks on the livestream also
lots of good comments